allez allez on y va
la prochaine fois j'y arriver
excusez-nous c'est possible de sortir
s'ils ont d'écriture et de travail
acharné pour tourner ce court métrage
qui porte sur un sujet universel comment
s'occuper de nos anciens attention
réalisatrice c'est aussi premier rôle
Lorraine Thomas a écrit un scénario qui
questionne sur le choix que l'on laisse
à une personne âgée sur son placement
dans un établissement un film écrit en
souvenir de son grand-père il m'a
demandé de lui tenir une promesse et
cette promesse c'était qui n'aille
jamais en institution j'avais qu'un 16
ans je dis mais oui pépé tu as 11
enfants voilà il y a pas de souci sauf
que quelques années après la famille
par maman je tiens à dire à décider de
placer mes grands-parents il est décédé
en quelques mois et avant qu'il parte je
lui ai dit
j'écrirai où je ferai un film je te le
promets
je te promets dans le scénario Daniel
Evenou 80 ans et laissé dans cette
petite maison de retraite qui compte une
soixantaine de résidents un lieu bien
différent au géant de ce secteur
dénoncer à plusieurs reprises pour leur
pratique
là nous sommes dans un lieu
où ça ne sent pas l'EHPAD ça ne sent pas
la mort ça ne sent pas c'est
absolument respectueux le travail que
ces gens font ici le film est porté par
un duo bien connu du grand public ils
vont le boloquet Bruno Solo ce dernier
joue le rôle du fils qui souhaite placer
sa mère
on voit qu'il a le droit pour sa maman
mais je crois que sur tout sa maman
qu'on voulait en voyant le film a eu un
accident et donc il a très peur que si
jamais
un Noël accident puis il y ait personne
pour pouvoir l'aider donc ils ont dit
autant la mettre dans une maison où il y
a des gens susceptibles de la de l'aider
mais on sent aussi qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est de l'ordre de j'ai plus le
temps ça va me prendre toute ma vie il y
a une angoisse un peu égoïste qui le
rattrape grâce à des subventions comme
l'agence régionale de santé de la région
Centre et des donateurs en ligne le film
a pu être tourné une nouvelle campagne
de financement va avoir le jour afin de
le monter et le distribuer avant la fin
de l'année
[Applaudissements]